new video shows the dramatic rescue of
survivors from a plane crash in Alaska
the Coast Guard released this footage
overnight it shows a rescue helicopter
hovering 100 feet above the rocky crash
site the 11 survivors were hoisted off
mount jumbo on Prince of Wales Island
where it went down on the way to catch a
can Kris Van Cleave spoke to the Coast
Guard crew members behind the operation
Kris good morning good morning
investigators say one thing is clear the
people on that plane are very lucky it's
increasingly looking like the plane
essentially flew into the side of a
mountain the pilot told the NTSB by the
time he realized he was in trouble he
was out of time the camera on the Coast
Guard helicopters hoist shows the daring
rescue operation under deteriorating
conditions hovering just 100 feet above
the crashed plane on Alaska's mount
jumbo to get everyone out the chopper
was filled to capacity
survivors congratulated each other
inside after cheating death pilot Joe
Plunkett a rescue swimmer Tony Puglia
say their crew braved bad weather and
dwindling fuel to find the wreckage
flying as close as 50 feet from the side
of the mountain through near blinding
fog at times unable to see the ground
they talked to CBS News via FaceTime
from a remote Alaska airstrip the
injuries weren't like incredibly severe
and there were fatalities the pilot of
this two Havilland Otter 72 year old
Mike Hudgens told investigators his
flight plan went through mountainous
terrain after taking off he ran into
clouds at about 1,100 feet with
visibility decreasing and as the weather
got worse he essentially became
disoriented to the plane's position when
he saw the mountains rising around the
plane he tried to climb but it was too
late
passenger ginny hacker iseman thanked
the Coast Guard crew on Facebook those
brave men put their lives on the line
for us I know that we would have never
lasted the night up there about five
minutes to get out of there we were very
lucky that's remarkable
you guys
worried we were sweating for the whole
time at last report two of the eleven
people on board remain hospitalized they
are expected to survive the company that
owns the plane praised Hudgens as a
skilled professional with thousands of
hours of flying experience in Alaska
Alex what a dramatic story thanks Chris